so this game is designed this class is
gonna be about power about palms so I
found this game that I played actually
recently against good friend of mine
Alex only shook and this is the first
round of the US Championship so I am
playing with the white black pieces
against Grandmaster honest Chuck so d 4
is 6 I played this prove I just wanted
to see his reaction because you know if
people play e4 then I can trust
if he plays before I can transpose into
Knight d5 that way I have transposition
to the French defense so that is the
point of d4e 6 because if you place a 4
I can transpose into the French defense
from my opponent is not an e4 player so
he played a move c4 I play f5 Knight c3
played by honest Suge Knight of 6 g3
so he just wants to put the [ __ ]
punished to this this move order
actually a little bit a little bit
tricky because if you play Knight f3 if
you play Knight f3 why can't play
actually a strong mobile ship before and
it's kind of complicated but the Moochie
trees you know quite tricky to deal with
because he just wants to play the move
Bishop g2 and then it will be very
difficult for me to play b6 Bishop d7 at
some point so this g3 is quite annoying
so I play d5 trying to get a stone wall
Bishop g2 c6
Knight h3 Bishop d6 Knight ich liebe
should be sixty castles I Castle and now
he played a move I'm gonna put in
training mood so you don't see the moves
cuz I'm gonna ask you to find it so this
is a position so Kosta Kosta he plays
Queen c2 now how should I proceed here
what ideas here the alternatives here
for me the move I played is a little bit
risky but it does give me some chances
to play for a win so I was you know
ashish takes on c4 yes okay this is not
a typical decision for this opening you
know this is the Dodge Stonewall so this
is not a typical but I wanted to get
some kind of complicated position and
you don't want the structure to be just
fixed so where it's easier for y to play
because if I don't do that then white
plays Bishop f4 treats the bishop
structure is fixed and he's sort of
enjoying a slightly better position I
think so I took it's a risky move I
think my opponent played well here he
played a four that's the drawback of
taking on c4 I lose the control of four
three four so when we place a four here
now what is the threat do you see the
threat what is it trying to do here what
is it threatening
yes he's working a dd5
Adi yes he is threatening to fork these
two pieces so the question is now how to
deal with this threat so at first I was
thinking okay I play Bishop e7 or Bishop
b4 which I think are okay moves but then
somehow I plays very risk in this game
but it worked out it happens sometimes
you take free play risky and you get we
go through a dangerous position but you
end up in a in a good position
later so sometimes it pays up this was
one of those cases I mean it kind of
paid off my risk so not always it does
but in this case it did so what did I
play here some of you might remember
this game because it was played right
here in the first round of the US
Championship so some of you might
remember this game or later on
especially the the finish was very nice
the ending of this game so let's see
here what did I play here ah dd5
absolutely it's it's risky because I am
NOT developed you know you're not
supposed to play like this you know when
you not develop this is usually doesn't
work and there's got me do a little bit
of a trouble but it was complicated it
was never a big big trouble in what he
was you know little bit shaky at some
point so he took which I was expecting
it I took it looks like wow I had these
two wonderful pants in the middle all I
got to do is protect them finish up my
development things should be easy but
very strong response 92 and suddenly I
have a problem here I have two pounds
that are hanging and very difficult to
do anything
both pounds are hanging so now if I play
d3 he plays Quincy forecheck so what to
do here yes because if I lose all these
pawns I'll be in big trouble so I don't
want to lose all these pawns so we got
Ashish they're raising his hand go ahead
Ashish see if I yc5 you're ready to give
up c4 okay well
[Music]
it's better to lose c4 by hang on to d4
so but he takes check he goes here and
this is a critical moment here I'm gonna
flip it to your side here and my
opponent played 95 which is a very
logical move but here he had a very
powerful move here and the reason I was
hesitant because I was really afraid of
this move
absolutely it's actually very strong
this is what I was afraid of I would go
for this if not before but before I was
like I didn't have a better choice so I
went for it but before it's extremely
strong move here the point is I cannot
play b6 I cannot hang on to my I'm
losing upon here actually because like
this would be a real disaster this 95-96
bit should be too it's just it's just
very bad for me so this is seriously bad
so I have to play this month 96 takes
and Bishop e5 and some complications are
currently here the white is better white
is better but not so simple okay
white is better but not so simple okay
yeah I was really afraid of before
because I saw this idea because it's
typical you break the position you
usually break the center when you have a
lead in development but he played a
knight excuse me no you played 95 I
don't think he's ready if he said he
would have played it I think or maybe he
didn't like it I don't know but I think
it's very strong because I suspicion
goes on b2 next so it's very very
powerful so he goes here 95
96 I'm not afraid to lose the exchange
so he plays Bishop f4 in fact if he
plays Knight f7 I think I'm better take
take here attack yeah
c4 d3 my pawns are rolling then I can
take on I fight this pawns are quite
strong so I think I'm doing fine here so
he played Bishop f4 trying to trade now
I gotta take this pawn Knight of several
takes Queen takes I'm down Lee exchange
but I have a pawn I have a pawn in a
knight for a look so technically I'm
down upon but I have a photon to
majority and three on - it's not gonna
be darrell event at the moment because
it can do too much but the problem is
might be so many changing so what do I
do against this now how do I try to
protect what would be the proper way to
defend it sometimes you just need to
play calm you know you don't have to
sometimes you just need to play calm
moves and improve your position you
don't have to do anything really really
complicated okay huh better better
little bit better than that
huh
but why Quinn why are you moving the
Quinn you have a rook there on edge
right guys what is the rook doing on an
age sitting there on the target yeah on
G to Bishop so what are we gonna do of
course you're gonna play with p8
protecting it now he was Bishop takes c6
he takes the knight now what you gonna
do Bishop takes c6 pawn takes c6 now the
pawn on b2 is hanging pollen be to
singing now what do you do so Bishop
rook e1
he's trying to use this rook on any file
to put pressure yes and now if he moves
you take on f4 you weaken the position
okay so that forces the capture I
captured back now his b2 pawn is also
hanging at some point but he plays the
move of p8 so he tastes 93 now I cannot
take because of which move rook e8 yeah
so this would be a blunder because of
rook e8
so you always have to watch out for the
background so now this we're talking
about the push past palms right so when
we have a passed pawn push further you
push stronger it gets
now he goes through key seven his Knight
is doing a good job controlling so he's
activating his rook yeah rook she ate
prophetic protecting g7 now what do you
do huh yeah I mean you know what is what
is black threatening here Bishop c4 yeah
Bishop g4 or you know
so please root k7 he just takes the pawn
you know that's a useful pawn because
now at some point he may start pushing
his pawn as well so here I have couple
of options in fact when I analyze the
game later on with the computer he
didn't even like my move
he didn't think I play the strongest
move absolutely I played Bishop g4 by
the way computer preferred move was like
Queen d3
you know like with idea queen d3 Queen
c2 and apparently black is winning it
can really defend so but I play the
natural MOBA ship seafood because now
I'm threatening to play you know ok d1
at some point and I didn't think he had
any other moves except abstract except
Queen e7 because otherwise I'm just
gonna go d1 so he played here and now
again maybe Queen d3 would have been
better here but I had a specific idea in
mind so I went just for that idea
okay yeah you're right there yeah
okay what did I play here Ashish queen
takes is seven rook takes is 795 the
point is if he takes my knight
I take back with a pawn and I'm just
promoting the D pawn right so if he
takes here I just take and I promote do
you want okay he had he had a good
defense here but he made the move that
him a blunder so he made a losing move
he played
Luke II to thinking that if I take on
its III he can take on the two and his
okay there and if I play Bishop e2 he
takes back with a night only two he's
maybe okay there too as well but he
missed like a really nice idea here that
wins the game on the spot and after my
next one he's simply resigned let's see
yes
promotes the pawn excellent yes it's a
tricky one I quit so I forced the other
rook to d1 because if Knight takes I
just pick up for free so and of course
he realized immediately that this is
just overnight c3 both rooks are hanging
Bishop e2 and I'm up a whole Bishop here
so he simply resigned after the move d1
but he has an interesting defensive
resources I saw this resource and I was
like hoping he didn't find it you know
because after this resource
maybe I'm winning here but it's a big
maybe okay so let's see here who can
find the best defense here best defense
for white no rookie three I don't think
you can hold
okay you get couple of pounds I mean I
can take on c3 this is what a shish is
suggesting but this is a cake I mean I
can't even go here you know this could
get actually really tricky now and then
I promote and do some background stuff
okay so you have to be careful okay all
right
it's not that it's not that
what are you saying Ashish
okay I don't have to give you my palms I
know you want to take all the pants and
then maybe claim some chances here but
I'm not gonna give it the pawns okay a
very clever idea but you really want to
go rook d7 here right you would love to
have this square to be able to control
after he takes on c2 but you don't have
that square right now is there a way to
get that square huh is there a way to
get that square somehow
Bishop D want
and he got it the young student
excellent yes f3 the point here is if
you take if I take only seven he takes
my bishop then this pawn is not going
anywhere if I take on City he goes BC if
I take which 50 it looks like I'm just
winning here but now why does the saving
move here rook d7 and he is winning the
palm back okay and this is gonna be a
drop after I played d1 so f3
I have to actually play Bishop takes f3
now look d7 at least for a moment he
stops me but it's very interesting he
doesn't have too many too many moles
it's almost like a sook serving here and
now who can find a powerful move because
I have problems on a background here so
I need this move here g5 correct yes
that will allow me to also establish a
good strength on f3 you know so I want
to try to do that
g4 to protect it and now king of two you
just played g4 or okay f8 ideas well say
if he takes on the fiber I take back
with a pawn pawn takes d5 now let's say
King f2
now what do you do before even in this
this works - this pushes him back
because he's from that file you know now
you're threatening d1 and if he goes
back to g1 the ultimate idea here is you
want to try to go here and take on beat
you back here G for now he has a he has
difficulty protecting b2 here and if he
goes let's say Knight do you want we
switch here threatening to go rookie to
now threatening to play rookie to check
so he has to go Knight c3 and now we
capture the captures we check if the
King goes back on g1 we have rook e1
check taking the rope if it goes here we
take this check take that glass wall
that's the idea okay let's review this
game we have some students who came late
so they can see the entire game as well
and that way we can practice it so let's
see if you remember the entire game
go ahead he's 6 since I'm a French
player I can start with this move order
because if he plays efore I can
transpose into French so C 4 and now
surprise for my opponent here they're
593 HD drizzle with idea Bishop g2 III
didn't want to go to snow mo but then I
didn't have too many other alternatives
I went here and now we have Dutch
Stonewall right Knight h3 castle
bishop here
Queen c2 and here risky decision I'm not
saying it's the best but it's a risky
decision but an interesting one now he
plays he for trying to threaten me he's
trying to play v e5 yes yes I'm winning
a pawn by the way yeah that's an extra
pawn now I'm not just doubling it I'm
actually picking up a pawn here hey one
day I'm hoping maybe this one will be
something but it's risky though very
risky play but you gotta take risk if
you're playing strong grandmasters with
block if you don't want to take any risk
you're not gonna get too many chances so
this way I went through some dangerous
position but got some chances some you
know imbalance you know II five correct
takes
now he goes 90 to it now pressuring on
d4 and also pressuring on c4 c5
protecting it
Quincy forecheck King h8 and this is the
moment where I was worried because he
had this move in mind you know I was
like worried if he plays this move
I didn't like my position down much
which move I'm talking about that he
should have played before excellent yes
this was a very strong wolf and I have
to play 96 and go for this which is some
really sharp lines f4 d3 and gets really
messy okay it looks like white is a
little bit better it's like one of the
lines is like this is this 95 b5 so it's
some sharp lines white is a little bit
better there the way he played actually
I thought my position was more or less
fine you know Knights what's the move
Bishop f4
took p8 protecting it he took on c6
Brooke fe1 d3 now is the Night Moves I
take on a for weekend the structure so
you took here now it goes here
rook e8 huh
Bishop g4 again Queen Detrick Queen c2
was probably stronger Queen d7 take take
Knight d5 and now okay he played rookie
- which lost to d1 Queen he resigned
because loses the piece it takes we'll
look I take take so the only move here
to stay in a game was f3 exclamation
mark I take now again I'm threatening to
take on City 8 it's hard to play after E
because it doesn't look like it's gonna
do much I mean Bishop looks like very
strong there but route d7 G 5 I saw this
man I knew I'm gonna have to play this
move to cement to get my king for the
background threats and also cement the
position of the bishop I like this I
think I have good advantage here so if
they here look afraid and Google enter
into the second rank only once has to go
here check yeah this looks really good
ok ok thanks everybody for coming for
this class so we're gonna have a short
break and we'll have another class
starting immediately okay all right
[Music]